c'est des scénarios etc des moments que
j'espère que jamais jamais mon
organisation va avoir à revivre pour
nous msf la crise d'ebola aurait été je
vous redis une des crises de plus
difficile humainement aviv est une des
crises ou est-ce qu'on a perdu plus de
personnel
un moment donné mon équipe même si nous
on n'est pas sûr qu'on a envie de rester
ici on n'a pas envie d'être encore des
accompagnants vers la mort de centaines
de patients puis d'être les seuls à se
prendre tout seul quand le reste de la
terre restent dans leur salon en garder
sa télé ça c'est pas vrai et même un
moment donné on a considéré est ce qu'on
doit partir
est ce qu'on doit partir est-ce que ça
va être le meilleur message au reste du
monde pour leur dire ça peut pour
continuer comme ça
vu l'ampleur du nombre de cas moi j'ai
plutôt rêver d'un vaccin
je me rappelle même d'avoir fait une
entrevue à radio-canada obligeamment
demander qu'est ce que je voulais juste
lui demande au père noël avec ça
je pense que c'est une question d'état
d'esprit a développé une question de
préparation mentale par rapport à une
prochaine épidémie et il le fait que
c'est vraiment important aujourd'hui de
déçus mais l'interdépendance planétaire
qu'on a aujourd'hui est qu'on peut pas
se permettre de dire que parce que ça se
passe à des kilomètres et des kilomètres
d'ici que c'est pas notre business parce
qu'aujourd'hui tout est notre business